dea
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
日本と欧米の文化は根本的に違うよって日本に来て間もない外国人の多くは実は普段
から文化タブをたくさんお越している日本に行ってみたようなたがそうならないように
今日は日本では絶対にやってはいけないことをいくつかショー
返したいと思うとてもビックリするかもしれないがこれが文化の違いです
日本はこういう国なんです
殺人車の盗難最高裁判所で偽証すること
絶滅寸前の誕生鶴を密漁して唐揚げにすること
ディズニーランドに期間中5名
落ち込むことディズニーシーに行ってせる火を取らないこと
なりすまし犯罪偽札を10億円ほど作ってこっそりとしないにばらまくこと3%の因習
でビジネスみんみんについての卒論を盗作すること暇つぶしとして記者を人質に取る
こと隣人に対する反逆つまり京阪略国家に対するある
逆つまり大逆ジャニーズに対する侮辱
つまり冒涜罪罰規模の立つ税は色を使って悪魔の教会を建てそこから得た力とコネで
新宿で刀剣団体をつくりそこから儲かったお金で池袋で地下人身売買ビジネスを
立ち上げること
アクションをなすこと餓死寸前の人喰い巡視を満員電車に誘導することを4次会の先生
の自宅に炭疽菌の手紙が送ることを覚醒剤はパートで作ることペロー員を高校生に配る
こと公然猥褻ひき逃げ暴行だ踏めことが受け止めること
いい音しなくていいからねんっ
ni